on sait que pour son action une
cérémonie à la mémoire des quatre cent
mille victimes de l'aco vide
le premier geste de joe biden à son
arrivée à washington avec un message
pour pouvoir se rétablir
il faut d'abord se souvenir tout j'ai au
moins lui même il avait promis d'en
faire la priorité des priorités
depuis son entrée en fonction le nouveau
président a placé la lutte contre la
pandémie au centre de son action
le monde
l'objet de son premier décret
présidentiel signé tout de suite après
son assermentation
aujourd'hui ils annoncent un plan
ambitieux un effort de guerre nécessaire
dit il car le virus a tué plus
d'américains que la deuxième guerre
mondiale
or que font usage de ses objectifs
premiers vaccinés 100 millions personnes
en 100 jours
skinny mairie ponote
et d'ici là il demande aux américains de
tous porter un masque pour le streak est
un geste patriotique selon lui oui deux
de ses humeurs qui pourrait sauver lui
seul 50 mille vies d'ici le mois d'avril
oui c'est one fifty pas aussi noir autre
mesure un test qu'ovide obligatoire à
l'entrée aux états unis une quarantaine
aussi joe biden fait enfin une promesse
aux américains sainz n'a pas toutes les
décisions concernant la pandémie seront
guidés par la science et non plus par la
politique
dorénavant dit il
c'est le docteur pham chi que vous
entendrez sur ce sujet et non plus le
président jacques chirac
acteur fao çi clairement soulagé de ne
plus avoir à composer avec d'autres et
si jean françois bélanger radio-canada
washington